this is going to cook in a unique way
let's go do it I need to wash my hand
first before we can eat I need to find
the
oven we couldn't be any deeper in the
soup this is where all the locals come
for their breakfast lunch and
dinner which way left left left
left is it here come here are you sure
we are in the right
place
hello come down come down now this is
the oven oh feel that heat oh [__]
that's beetroot there and just Shuffle
you know what I love this country it's
like we're going back to biblical time
these ancient Community ovens can be
found all over the Medina as most people
who live here don't have one at home
whilst that's cooking slowly we're going
to have a Haman what's a Haman it's like
medieval Spar you know see those pipes
this generates all the steam into that
hamama and you know what traditionally
they come here drop this off Thursday
night pick it up on Friday morning and
literally have a h on in order to be
super clean ready for a big prayer day
and he's all men of course it's all men
time to bond come on we are men you know
they are very affectionate with each
other very intimate they all hands and
they do all these things together they C
the tanier they go to the amam
exactly you have no hair on your chest I
don't have [__] hair on much cuz I'm
not a hairy person you don't have any
hair stop nipping it you wax no I don't
wax do you shave no I don't shave do you
use cream instead
cream who what want you
[Music]
to this is
Beau that's
a full body exfoliation and massage the
perfect Christmas treat for metrosexual
men like
us he's taking off my
skin I feel it in my
fingers I feel it in my
[Applause]
toes
Christmas is all
around and so the feeling
grows you love chrristmas
come let
[Music]
it come
it I have to say Gordon I don't think
this is your best
ideas